Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Jetzt sind wir wieder kurz vorm Salon, denn es ist schon wieder ein Monatsbeginn. Es ist schon September. Ja, diesmal wirklich Bundestagswahl Monat.
Und da bist du jetzt ganz hibbelig oder was?
Geht.
Nein, eigentlich gar nicht. Ja, ich habe aber so viele andere Dinge und deswegen beschäftige ich mich überhaupt nicht damit. Also habe jetzt auch keine Wahlkampf Arena mir angesehen. Auch das gibt es ja auch noch, dass die Einzelkandidaten dort noch mal sich dem Publikum stellen. Das war wohl gestern Abend mit Baerbock, habe ich aber auch nicht geschaut.
Nee, ich habe es auch erst nur gehört, dass es das gibt. Aber ich werde es mir natürlich noch ohne Bild in dreifacher Geschwindigkeit einmal durchnudeln. Wir haben einen Audio, nicht ein Audio-Kommentar, wir haben einen normalen Schreibkommentar bekommen. Und da will ich mal kurz hinweisen. Wir publizieren ja so überall. Also das Video des Regulären kommt auch auf YouTube und der Salon hat eine eigene Steady-Seite und so weiter. Damit zum Beispiel Wolfgang alle Kommentare lesen kann, wäre es wirklich super, die einfach auf die neuezwanziger.de-Webseite zu stellen. Denn beim Salon gibt es jetzt auch keinen Admin-Zugang oder so. Da gibt es einfach nur, ich weiß nicht, warum die das bei Steady nicht machen, dass es mehr als ein Pro-Projekt gibt, der da mal zugreifen kann auf Kommentare und Textnachrichten. In der Hinsicht sind die dann einfach nicht sichtbar. Also da wäre es ganz gut, einfach die neuezwanziger-Seite zu nehmen. Bei YouTube, das habe ich langsam aufgegeben, Leute wollen da kommentieren und die Kommentarqualität ist auch entsprechend. Manchmal rutscht ja doch, nennst wer das Zeug da rein, einfach auf neuezwanziger.de und sei es als Kopie oder so. Aber dann kriegen wir es hier auch mit und dann sehen es auch alle. Und dann ist das auch gut. Und wir haben einen Kommentar bekommen auf die neuezwanziger-Seite, dass die Linken durchaus Kryptowährung verbieten wollen.
Ja und ich hätte es wissen müssen, denn wir haben es auch im Podcast glaube ich sogar erwähnt. Und ja, es steht im Programm, ich hatte es aber in dieser Schärfe nicht mehr so vor Augen. Aber die wollen es machen. Das wäre doch auch mal eine schöne Bedingung, irgendwie die die Linken stellen können. Also man will doch jetzt, dass die Linke die ganze Zeit so ein Bekenntnis zur NATO abgibt. Als sei jetzt auch, dass die Frage, dass wenn es diese rot-rot-grünere Koalition geben würde, dann wäre Deutschland im Januar aus der NATO draußen oder so. Das ist ja eh eigentlich irgendein Wunsch, vielleicht von Leuten. Ja, ja. Aber das wäre doch einfach mal schön, wenn man das mal kontert und sagt, also für uns ist keine Koalition möglich, wenn man nicht Krypto verbietet oder so.
Ja, genau. Das ist nämlich der Punkt. Bei den Linken steht ganz schön viel im Programm. Das ist aber bestimmt auch das Längste, kennt man ja so ein bisschen.
Die Grünen sind noch ein bisschen länger.
Aber immer große Wunschkonzerte.
Die beiden sind jedenfalls wahnsinnig gut ausgearbeitet. Also beide Programme sind wahnsinnig gut ausgearbeitet. Das fand ich sehr erstaunlich zu sehen.
Ja, ich habe vorhin erst wieder, ich weiß nicht genau, in welcher Diskussion, SVH2-Forum oder irgendwas, Deutschlandfunk oder so, noch mal den kleinen Hinweis bekommen, und wir haben ja auch das Buch von Sarah Warnknecht besprochen. Und es ist ja wirklich erstaunlich, dass Sarah Warnknecht 200 Seiten lang über das Thema schreibt, was sie eigentlich rausräumen will, nämlich Kulturkämpfe. Und die linke Politik, die sie promoten möchte, kommt in dem Buch ja nicht vor, aber im Wahlprogramm der Linken, von dem sie ja jede Sauerstoff zum Atmen genommen hat durch ihr Buch. Und das ist ja wirklich auch ein interessantes Paradox, wie sich die Linke da mal wieder selber im Weg steht. Ich hätte jetzt aber allerdings einen Vorschlag. Der Wahlkampf zieht auf die Zielgeraden ein. Und wir haben jetzt mittlerweile gehört, ich habe es ja mit Mick auch noch mal im Detail besprochen, es ist ja Wahnsinn, was man derzeit aus der CDU hört. Paul Ziemiak sitzt bei Andeville und sagt, wenn die SPD regiert, Zitat, verlieren wir alles und dann isolieren wir uns auch international. Und dann hat ja Kevin Kühnert gekontert mit, ich will mal sagen, dass Olaf Scholz, ich wiederhole, Olaf Scholz nicht die kommunistische Gewaltherrschaft einführt. Und anhand der Verbitterung und Verzweiflung der CDU, würde ich sagen, sollte es jetzt Olaf Scholzs Auftrag sein, den wir ihm jetzt noch mitgeben, also ihr Hörer, ihr habt jetzt besondere Verantwortung, das auf Twitter und so weiter so zu promoten, dass es Olaf Scholz mitbekommt. Olaf Scholz sollte bei den nächsten beiden Triellen, die stattfinden, am 12. und am 19. die nächsten beiden Sonntage, von Armin Laschet ein Bekenntnis abverlangen, nach der Bundestagswahl nicht Schwarz-Gelb-Blau anzustreben, also mit der AfD das Thüringer Modell durchzupeitschen. Wir wissen von CDU und FDP, dass sie zu so was in der Lage sind. Und deswegen, finde ich, ist es hier Zeit für ein Bekenntnis.
Genau, also man muss da immer den Spieß umdrehen, das ist eigentlich die sinnvollste Methode. Und das fehlt auch hier so ein bisschen. Also man kennt das doch aus dem amerikanischen Wahlkampf anders, dass da ganz anders auf Angriff gefahren wird. Und hier ist das doch alles sehr in der Defensive. Oder es gibt dann halt so einen Humbug-Wahlkampf, wie das jetzt da von der Jungen Union und sonstigen Leuten dann gemacht wird. Denn das ist ja so unterirdisch, zeigt aber, wie groß die Verzweiflung ist und zeigt ja auch, dass die einfach richtig was einzustecken haben. Also selbst wenn die dann doch noch stärker werden, es sind definitiv viele viele Pöstchen, die da wegfallen. Und da werden wahrscheinlich noch nicht alle untergekommen sein in irgendwelchen Vorständen und Lobby-Organisationen, sodass da einfach Leute um ihren Job bangen und deswegen auch so besonders aggressiv gerade reagieren.
Ja, so ein Wahltermin ist unglaublich unbarmherzig. Du glaubst, du hast einen festen Sitz, bist richtig reingesattelt ins Regierungsarbeiten und überhaupt. Und plötzlich ist so ein Wahltermin. Mir ist das eigentlich seit 2012 so richtig bewusst. Wir hatten 2013 eine Bundestagswahl, bei der die Piraten keine Rolle gespielt haben. 2012 werden sie mit 9, 10 Prozent eingezogen. Nur ein Jahr vorher. Wir hatten letztes Jahr eine Präsidentenwahl, als die CDU hier bei 38 Prozent stand, weil die CDU ist besser gemacht als Donald Trump. Donald Trump ist nämlich der einzige im Amt gewesen, der nicht davon profitiert hat, dass es gerade eine riesige Krise zu bewältigen gab. Alle hätten was draus gemacht, Donald Trump nicht. Die CDU hätte hier mit 35 Prozent oder so plus eingecashed. Und jetzt ist aber das einfach vorbei. Und die Zeit läuft jetzt in anders. Und jetzt muss ich damit klarkommen, was natürlich für uns einfach mal auch ein bisschen Durchatmen, Zufriedenheit bedeutet. Und wir können jetzt so durchsegeln wie du, müssen uns gar nicht dafür groß interessieren. Wir können uns darauf verlassen, die Trägheit ist groß genug. Ja, da verändert sich jetzt auch die nächsten zwei Wochen nicht mehr viel. Man kann sich nur noch das Theater anschauen und hoffen, dass viel davon bleibt.
Und dass die Umfragen stimmen, nicht, dass es dann doch noch ein bisschen anders alles kommt. Ich bin ja da sehr, sehr vorsichtig, was solche Prognosen anbelangt. Aber es sieht auf jeden Fall so aus, dass die CDU nicht gesetzt sein muss. Und davon gehen wir alle noch aus. Du hast es ja mal ganz drastisch hier gesagt. Also du hattest ja die SPD sehr abgemeldet. Und das war dann eine Überraschung. Aber das war wirklich für, glaube ich, die SPD auch eine Überraschung. Also das kann mir jetzt auch niemand erzählen, dass das jetzt die tolle Strategie war, die man schon im Herbst vergangenen Jahres sich ausgedacht hatte. Und jetzt sagt man, es ist aufgegangen, sondern man hat gesagt, wir wissen es nicht. Und jetzt gibt es dieses Fenster der Geschichte, das sich öffnet. Und die Frage ist, ob man durchgehen kann oder ob man nur mal guckt und dann doch wieder zumacht und sagt, ach ja, aber eine GroKo war doch eigentlich so schön. Und wir verstehen uns doch eigentlich auch so hinter den Kulissen ganz gut. Das sind ja auch immer noch Gefahren, die bei so Sachen mitschwingen. Also da ist ja alles möglich. Aber das überhaupt mal was möglich ist, ist ja nach 16 Jahren Merkel auch schon etwas angenehm ist.
Zur Sache der Strategie will ich mal noch sagen, es ist eigentlich noch ein bisschen schlimmer als, wie du es jetzt formuliert hast, dass es sozusagen nicht auf Eigenleistung Olaf Scholz zurückgeht. Denn Olaf Scholz hat ja durchaus eine Strategie gehabt, nur es waren die einzig mögliche überhaupt, nämlich irgendwie zu versuchen, diese Erbschleicherei, dass man den Wählern weiß macht, ich bin die bessere Merkel. Eigentlich wollen wir alle, dass Merkel abgewählt ist und auch das Prinzip Merkel. Also diese Verarmung, diese Verreicherung, die hier stattfand, die Nichtbeachtung des Klimas, die völlige Ausschließung, dass Digitalisierung eine Rolle spielt und so weiter. Also Zukunft spielt einfach keine Rolle. Und jetzt hat Olaf Scholz eigentlich genau inhaltlich das nicht gemacht, was man sich wünscht so in diesem Land. Aber er hat eben genau das gemacht, womit eine, ich sage jetzt mal in Anführungszeichen, linke Mehrheit möglich wäre. Nur das setzt halt wirklich zum einen voraus, dass Olaf Scholz, als es eigentlich nicht danach aussah, als hätte es Sinn und man könnte es auch nicht mit Verstand machen, auf dieses Pferd gesetzt hat. Und dann die CDU komplett scheiterte an sich selbst mit diesem sinnlosen Streit, Söder gegen Laschet und noch Laschet als Gewinner daraus. Also es sind ja sozusagen 0 zu 2 steht es dann dadurch. Und jetzt muss er aber auch verwandeln. Also wenn Olaf das jetzt nochmal versemmelt. Na ja und am Ende, man weiß es nicht, Beiden war auch abgeschrieben, auch von mir. Und dann kam er plötzlich ins Amt und hat die Billionen auf den Tisch gelegt.
Aber das sind dann große Konstellationen im Hintergrund, die man nicht finden kann. Man kann, wenn jetzt die Grünen doch relativ schwach sein sollten, also dann wird das sicherlich auch nochmal die Möglichkeit für Habeck, sich nach vorne zu stellen und zu sagen, ich habe da eigentlich eine Expertise zum Beispiel, könnte ich ja mit Finanzen anders umgehen. Also das Finanzministerium wäre ja, wenn die SPD gewinnt jedenfalls in der Hand von den Grünen, wahrscheinlich nicht bei den Linken, aber doch bei den Grünen dann und dann wäre Habeck vielleicht ein Kandidat, sicherlich nicht Baerbock als Finanzministerin, die hätte wahrscheinlich auch andere Ideen, was sie machen könnte. Aber das ist ganz aufregend eigentlich dann zu sehen, was da so passiert. Aber lass uns doch noch ganz kurz über den Streit der Virologen noch mal sprechen. Also wir haben ja den nochmal neu entfacht bekommen, jetzt dadurch, dass Jan Böhmermann mit Giovanni di Lorenzo Marcos Lanz auf einem Podium saß und dann Lanz vorwarf, dass er vielen Leuten die menschenfeindliche Position vertreten, ein Forum in der Sendung geben würde. Nun bin ich ja auch ein Talkshow-Hasser, habe aber Lanz auch immer etwas daraus genommen. Also ich hasse diese Polit-Talkshows. Finde Lanz mitunter sehr gut, auch wenn ich das nicht in so einer Regelmäßigkeit mir ansehe. Ich gucke es auch tatsächlich lieber, wenn irgendwelche Promi-Stars sitzen, irgendwelche Stars von einst, die erzählen als jetzt Politiker. Und ja, es gibt generell in Talkshows diese Tendenz, dass wenn alle Menschen sagen, Feinstaub ist nicht so gut, und es gibt aber noch einen Forscher, der sagt, für Kinder ist das besonders toll, wenn die am Auspuff schnuppern, dann wird der auch mal eingeladen. Das ist tatsächlich so eine Tendenz. Die hat ja Herbert Markuse schon als repressive Toleranz gedeutet. Das heißt, es gibt schon eine gewisse Vorsicht, die man walten lassen sollte, wenn man diese Radikalposition mit rein nimmt, weil man immer auch die damit schon aufwertet natürlich. Und er ist auch ganz für eine Diskursbeschränkung. Und das sieht man natürlich in manchen Debatten anders. Und ich finde aber dann das doch etwas problematisch, wenn man dann für das Beispiel Menschen verachtende Positionen, Hendrik Streeck, damit rein nimmt und auch noch Kekulé bzw. sagt, ich werde jetzt mal beurteilen, dass diese beiden keine Expertise haben, weil Kekulé momentan nicht mehr forscht und bei Streeck weiß ich nicht. Und dann sagt ja Lanz, na ja, Kekulé hat immer wieder die Bundesregierung in solchen Dingen beraten. Der mag zwar aktuell nicht im Labor stehen, aber natürlich ist das eine Experte auf dem Gebiet. Und auch bei Streeck haben wir es ja mit jemandem zu tun, der sich schon einige Lorbeeren erworben hat. Auch wenn ich mit Streeck selten d'accord gehe und den auch nicht besonders sympathisch finde. Und bei Kekulé aber sagen kann, na ja, was er zu Thema Astra im Stoff zweiter Klasse gesagt hat, war ja Gold richtig, wurde noch richtiger durch die Delta-Variante. Da hat Rosten sich rausgewunden, da hat Maity auch nicht aufgeklärt, in dem Sinne, wie man das eigentlich von ihr erwarten müsste. Und auch gerade bei Maity könnte man ja sagen, ja, hat sie denn eine Expertise, warum sie forscht? Ja, und ich gerade, sie ist Chemikerin, hat eigentlich mit wir nichts zu tun und trotzdem sagen wir ja, gut, dass die das macht, die klärt da auf.
Also das ist diese Preise alle und geben mir diese Preise.
Also das ist eine ganz merkwürdige Einteilung, die da gemacht wird. Und ich würde da doch mal Vorsicht walten lassen, also wie man auf so eine Position kommen kann, nur weil einem die Position von Streeck, also diese Idee mit dem Virusleben, nicht gefällt. Und ich will jetzt mal eine neue provokante These hier bringen. Ich war ja auf der Phil Cologne und das war alles ganz wunderbar. Und dann sitzt man natürlich auch noch mit vielen Leuten zusammen. Und da würde ich sagen, ist jetzt auch, also es gab jetzt kein großes virologisches Gespräch, aber ich würde sagen, die Sympathien liegen doch mehr da, so für die Aussagen von Jan Böhmermann als, dass man sich jetzt mit Streek solidarisieren will. Und dann hört man aber so von all diesen Leuten, und ich hab's ja auch alles bei Insta und Twitter durch meine ganze Recherche sowieso verfolgt, dass ja diese Leute, die das so hart fordern, Lockdown, oder auf keinen Fall darf man darüber reden, wie man mit dem Virus leben kann, die haben ja dann doch ganz anders gehandelt, indem sie permanent in Fernsehstudios saßen, permanent ihre Comedy-Podcasts deutschlandweit aufgenommen haben und und und. Sie waren ja alle nur unterwegs. Und so habe ich das auch wieder da festgestellt. Das waren alles Leute, die mir so aus den Lockdown-Zeiten, die ich ja wirklich zu Hause verpackt habe, die ganze Zeit erzählten, wo sie überall waren. Und jetzt kommt meine These. Also die Leute, also so ich sag mal die Medien-Promi-Elite, die hat eigentlich die ganze Zeit nach dem Prinzip streng mit dem Virus leben gehandelt. Hat aber gleichzeitig bei Twitter, Insta und so weiter gesagt, nein, Lockdown, Team-Trosten. Und jetzt fragt man sich natürlich, warum. Jetzt kann man einfach sagen, das ist eine Doppelmoral. Das stimmt auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube, es geht sogar noch weiter. Also wenn man ein bisschen Lacan oder so gelesen hat, dann kann man das, glaube ich, nachvollziehen. Und zwar, glaube ich, genießt man zum einen dieses, mit dem Virus leben, dass man diese privilegierte Position hat, Fernsehstudio, alles desinfiziert, alle Mitarbeiter um einen herum. Das habe ich jetzt auch wieder bei der Erfüllung. Während Wuseln mit Maske um einen herum. Man selbst hat aber natürlich dann keine Maske an und so. Alles immer so toll privilegiert. Und dann erlaubt es einem aber, Twitter, wenn man da die Team-Trosten, harter Lockdown, Zero-Covid-Jetzt-Position einnimmt, dass man auch noch genießen kann, dagegen zu sein. Es ist ein bisschen wie das, was wir hatten bei dem, ich glaube, polnischen Politiker, EU-Politiker, der in Polen ein homophobes Gesetz durchbringt, um dann an einer schwulen Orgie in Brüssel teilzunehmen. Und es ist nicht nur Doppelmoral, sondern man genießt beides. Man genießt die schwule Orgie wie auch noch gegen die schwule Orgie zu sein. Und ich glaube, diese beiden Sachen können wir da sehr, sehr gut beobachten.
Wir haben ja schon häufiger hier über Drosten gesprochen und uns immer wieder gewundert, warum ihm nicht richtig zugehört wird. Und weil du ja auch noch mal jetzt Drosten so ins andere Lager als Kiko Leuenstrieck.
Zu dem er gar nicht so gehört.
Genau. Ich will jetzt noch mal reproduzieren, replizieren, was Drosten in seinem aktuellen, in seinem jüngsten Podcast jetzt gesagt hat. Nämlich und ich führe noch mal kurz einen kleinen Exkurs ein. Ich gucke mal mit Thomas einmal im Monat das englische Fernsehen und da saß schon vor drei, vier Monaten ein Regierungsberater im Gespräch mit den Journalisten und meinte, wenn sie zweifach geimpft sind, ist die natürliche Infektion wünschenswert. Desireble. Wünschenswert. Und das war damals zu einer Zeit, als das in Deutschland völlig unsagbar war. Eigentlich müssen wir uns jetzt alle durch infizieren. Also richtig durch infizieren. Habt keine Angst vor dem schrecklichen Wort durch infizieren, sondern durch infizieren. Und jetzt höre ich Drosten, wundere mich noch ein bisschen über die Audioqualität. Der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk kriegt es immer noch nicht hin, ordentliche Podcasts zu machen. Und stelle fest, dass Drosten genau diese Ansicht ist. Wie keine dritte Impfung, weil ja es wäre zwar cool, wenn wir eine dritte Impfung haben, aber wir müssen jetzt wirklich mal an die Welt denken. Also das Georg Maskulo Mantra, was er schon seit einem Jahr predigt. Wir müssen jetzt an die Welt denken. Keine dritte Impfung, weder jetzt und auch nicht nächstes Jahr und auch nicht übernächstes Jahr. Denn jetzt wäre es gut, dann auch infiziert zu werden, um das Virus, der Körper kennt es jetzt, das Virus mit dem Körper bekannt zu machen und darüber dann die dauerhafte lebenslange Immunität aufzubauen. Das Virus kommt dann einfach immer mal wieder vorbei, so wie auch die anderen ersten vier Coronaviren. Also auch Drosten wünscht sich jetzt die natürliche Infektion für sich selber, um einfach mit dem Virus leben gelernt, nicht jedes Frühjahr wieder Update, Impfung und so weiter, sondern dann einfach wirklich mit dem Virus zu leben. Ganz individuell. Und das fand ich sehr bemerkenswert.
Aber das ist ja kaum rezipiert worden.
Gar nicht, gar nicht, gar nicht, gar nicht. Und das finde ich immer wieder so überraschend. Das war alles so Drosten, Drosten, Drosten. Während Drosten schon immer fand ich, Drosten hat ganz früh diese eigene Studie gemacht zur Validität der Antigen-Tests, als das hier noch gar keiner hören wollte. Dann setzte sich das so langsam durch. Und jetzt kommt Drosten aber und sagt, naja, mit dem Testen, das war eigentlich eine Brückentechnologie. Wir haben jetzt Impfung. Wer sich nicht impfen lässt, entscheidet sich ja bewusst, das hat er schon vor ein paar Monaten gesagt, für die Infektion. Und er hat ja auch in diesem aktuellen Podcast, der sozusagen der zweite Kern dieses Podcasts, und das ist auch die Frage, die ich jetzt noch mal habe, an euch alle. Ich verstehe das Prinzip 3G nicht, überhaupt gar nicht. Denn es ist genau die Situation, die Drosten beschreibt, erlebe ich jetzt mehrfach die Woche. Man hat Kinder, man hat Vereinskollegen, man will wieder Sport machen, das läuft auch wieder. Die Inzidenz in Frankfurt ist 150. Und wir haben keine Einschränkungen über die Hygienemaßnahmen. Ja, also Masken mit einem Haufen in den Bus fahren. Aber es macht jetzt keiner die Vereinstätigkeiten wieder zu und sagt, nee, ihr dürft nicht abends in die Halle. Und wenn es kalt ist, auch mal die Türen zu machen und so. Und es ist ja nun diese folgende Situation, wie Drosten sie beschrieben hat. Da sind 15 Leute in einer Turnhalle.
Infiziert meint sie, nur um das kurz jetzt klarzustellen, für mich nicht Impfdurchbruch, sondern ich bin dann Träger dieses Virus, habe es, habe aber keine, im besten Fall symptomlos.
Das verspricht ja auch. Das sieht man ja auch in den Zahlen jetzt in Amerika.
Und bei Impfdurchbruch sprechen wir also davon, dass dieses Virus dann wirklich was Hartes bei mir verursacht? Oder ist Impfdurchbruch auch einfach nur, dass ich dann infiziert bin?
Also Impfdurchbruch heißt, du hast wirklich Symptome durch die Infektion. Also das bricht die Krankheit durch. Nicht in der Härte, dass es irgendwie nennenswert ist. Aber es ist eben bemerkbar, es ist sozusagen Anlass für einen Test, würde ich sagen. So und das ist nämlich der Punkt. Die RNA-Impfstoffe von Moderna und BioNTech wurden uns ja mit so 95 Prozent Wirksamkeit angepriesen. Das geht natürlich auf die Alpha-Variante zurück. Ist bei Delta auch nicht nennenswert schlechter, daran geht es so im 80er-Bereich. Aber wir machen im Grunde die Infektion symptomlos durch, sind aber infiziert. Das ist ja bei Delta ganz wichtig. Das Immunsystem greift, aber nicht auf der Schleimhaut, da wo das Virus anfängt zu replizieren, wo man auch zwei Tage lang wirklich die Dosis raushaut. Und jetzt haben wir ja wirklich folgende Situation, die absolut nicht passt zu dem, was wir die letzten anderthalb Jahre gemacht haben, dass 15 Leute in einer Turnhalle irgendeinem Sport nachgehen, alle geimpft sind. Und jetzt meine Situation, wir waren zu zwölf gestern in einer Turnhalle, die Türen waren zu, alles war zu, es war einfach ganz normale Turnhallen-Situation. Und dann kommt ein 16ter dazu, von dem alle wissen, der ist nicht geimpft, und sagt, ja gut, dann teste ich mich jetzt mal. Und dann habe ich ihn so angeguckt und fragte, warum testest du dich? Also für uns, du kannst uns nicht infizieren. Uns ist egal, ob du gerade Corona mitbringst oder nicht. Nur das umgedrehte Szenario, dass wir uns für dich testen, dass du sicher sein kannst, du kriegst es gerade nicht von uns asymptomatisch weiter. Das ist natürlich ausgeschlossen. Wir gehen jetzt nicht zu 15 hier in Pause und testen uns.
Nur weil einer keine Lust hat, sich impfen zu lassen.
Genau, 15 mal 5 Euro aus und produzieren so ein Müllberg. Und das wird ja auch nicht verlangt, dass wir uns für den, die einen testen. Also es sind jetzt durch die 3G-Regel sehr viele einzelne, nur getestete, aber ungeimpfte Menschen, nicht genesen, nicht geimpft, also absolut naiv für das Virus in Empfänglichkeit, die nicht geschützt werden durch 3G.
Und die werden jetzt wahrscheinlich mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit infiziert von einem Geimpften.
Genau, das ist die Durchseuchung. Und wir diskutieren unendlich viele Sachen mit den Schülern und so weiter. Die Schüler tragen weiter Maske. Ich habe 3 U12-Kinder, ich habe null Sorgen vor Corona bei meinen Kindern, weil die Statistik einfach zeigt, es ist wirklich kein nennenswertes Problem. Seltene Krankheiten beginnen bei 1 zu 20.000 und nicht bei 1 zu 100.000 oder so was. Also wir haben es wirklich mit einer super seltenen Krankheit bei Corona, bei U12 zu tun. Die anderen können sich alle impfen. Und wir diskutieren als zweites am Arbeitsplatz, wo ich mir denke, was für eine alberne Diskussion, als ob sich nicht rumspricht in der Belegschaft, wer hier geimpft ist. Habe ich auch schon den Witz gemacht, dann macht man einfach eine Teambuilding-Maßnahme in Hamburg, in einem 2G-Lokal und dann sieht man ja, wen nicht mitkommt, weil er an der Tor abgewiesen wird. Und dann weiß man, wer hier nicht geimpft ist. Also am Arbeitsplatz, diese Diskussion finde ich albern, das wird sich auch in zwei Monaten ergeben. Dann weiß man, wer hier wie die Sachstande sind. Aber dass wir derzeit eine Freizeitaktivitäts-3G-Situation haben, bei der Ungeimpfte auch nicht wissen, wie gefährdet sie eigentlich sind, sondern reinkommen und sagen, die Regierung verlangt einen Test von mir, also mache ich jetzt einen Test und dann spiele ich halt. Das verstehe ich nicht. Weil ich habe dann wieder so den Eindruck, ich muss hier erst mal aufklären, dass wir alle infektiös sein können. Mit der Besonderheit, wir würden es echt nicht merken, wir sind ja geimpft. Also wir kriegen es ja in besonders hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit asymptomatisch. Und dann hast du da so Ungeimpfte zwischendrin, die dann einfach sagen, ist doch 3G, ich bin noch getestet. Und es ist genau das falsche Prinzip. Also das verstehe ich nicht, warum hier gerade nicht ein mega Aufschrei ist, um wirklich Leute zu schützen, denn wir haben 30% ungeimpft oder so, 30, 40%. Das sind ja wirklich krasse Zahlen. Aber es ist alles indoor offen. Es wird jetzt immer mehr indoor. Letzte gute Woche Sonne scheinen und so.
Ich will noch mal mein Pragmatismus-Argument nehmen und wundere mich immer noch, dass es nicht verfängt. Und wir hatten ja hier die Diskussion im vergangenen Salon. Was ist denn das Entscheidende? Der Preis, sagst du, also was sind Leute bereit zu zahlen und nicht? Und ich rede dann vom Bewusstsein, von der Ideologie. Dann verdrehst du die Augen. Aber hier, glaube ich, habe ich dann leider recht und habe aber selbst mir nicht geglaubt. Ich habe mir selbst nicht geglaubt und dachte, die Menschen sind pragmatisch, sie sind nicht so ideologisch. Aber es muss anders sein. Ich bin spazieren gegangen durch Koblenz am Abend am Samstag. Und dann sehe ich vor diesen Testzentren, zwei sind da auf diesem Weg, wenn ich da hergehe, wirklich eine lange Schlange stehen von Leuten, die ausgefertigt sind, halb neun abends ausgefertigt sind, die dann da stehen, bis sie dran sind für ihren Test. Dann müssen sie da die Viertelstunde warten. Und ich denke mir, wie unpragmatisch kann man sein? Warum nicht einmal diese Spritzer sich abholen und dann nie mehr um halb neun auf dem Bürgersteig zu stehen und zu warten, dass man da jetzt gleich ein Stäbchen in die Nase gesteckt bekommt?
Darf ich das nochmal strapazieren zum Ende?
Ja, mach mal.
Und zwar genau in diesem Konflikt muss es alles durchs Bewusstsein gedreht werden oder reicht nicht einfach ein sozusagen sozialkonformes Verhalten, möglichst frei von solchen Gedankengängen, wo muss ich mich hier wie in Sicherheit bringen und so weiter. Du hast ja auch betont, für dich ist Komfort am allerwichtigsten. Und Komfort heißt ja, den Weg zu wählen, ist nicht übers Bewusstsein drehen zu müssen. Wie ich auch schon in der Folge sagte, es gibt jetzt hier Mütter, die von mir lange auch als Impfgegner verunglimpft wurden, ohne dass ich sie namentlich nenne, die dann jetzt in WhatsApp schreiben, ich habe mir die Giftspritze geben lassen, damit ich mit meiner Tochter im Winter jetzt sozusagen alles machen kann, was ich machen will. Und das ist ja genau das, was die Spritze erlaubt, die Impfung. Dass du es nicht mehr durch dein Bewusstsein drehen musst, dass du einfach weißt, mein Körper macht das schon, mein Geist muss nicht mitspielen. Ja, und das ist ja genau die Ruhe, die du haben willst.
Genau, das werfe ich ja die Packungsbeilage weg, wenn ich Medikament nehme, weil ich das nicht in mein Bewusstsein reinbringen will. Ich gehe einfach davon aus, wir haben einigermaßen hohe Standards bei Medikamenten. Ich vertraue dem Arzt, der sie verschrieben hat, oder dem Apotheker, der sie mir verkauft hat. Und dann ist gut.
Ja, und das ist das Ziel.
Das ist die Motivation. Eine Sache will ich da noch ansprechen, wo wir jetzt gerade dabei sind. Es ist ja verrückt, dass man doch immer wieder auf dieses Thema kommt. Man merkt übrigens auch so im Bekanntenkreis, wenn die Leute so gerade nicht wissen, was sie sagen sollen, sagen sie ja mit dem Corona und dann geht sofort wieder eine Diskussion los. Also es ist sehr interessant. Aber wir spielen das mir hier noch ein bisschen weiter durch. Und zwar diese Sache, dass die Tests kostenpflichtig werden, ab, ich glaube, dem 11. Oktober, wurde zum Teil von Links kritisiert, weil gesagt wurde, das ist keine gute Idee, dann können sich ja Leute, die nicht viel Geld haben, sich die nicht mehr leisten und so weiter und so fort. Ich kann ehrlich gesagt diese Argumentation nicht nachvollziehen, denn wir hatten jetzt erst einmal sehr lange, in meinen Augen zu lange, die Möglichkeit gehabt, uns testen zu lassen, obwohl Impfungen schon zur Verfügung standen. Ja, man hätte also da vielleicht schon früher das stoppen können mit den kostenlosen Tests. Und wir haben ja eine kostenlose Alternative. Also die kostenlose Alternative heißt ja Impfung. Und diese Impfung ist gut und die ist sinnvoll und die tut auch gesellschaftlich uns was Gutes. Warum sollte man jetzt etwas, was uns nicht hilft, noch weiter alimentieren? Nur weil man sagt, ja, aber Leute, die viel Geld haben, können sich das ja weiterhin leisten. Ja, natürlich können die sich das weiterhin leisten. Aber das ist eine generelle Ungleichheit. Also das kann man jetzt überall natürlich anwenden und sagen, ja, aber die können sich das ja immer leisten. Klar, also Leute, die Geld haben, werden immer die Möglichkeit haben, sich in irgendeiner Weise zu privilegieren. Also wenn irgendwann der Individualverkehr abgeschafft sein sollte in Städten, wird es auch immer noch Möglichkeiten geben, für reiche Leute sich einzeln chauffieren zu lassen. Davon gehe ich aus. Ja, aber trotzdem würde man immer sagen, öffentlicher Nahverkehr wäre gut, wenn er gratis ist. Aber wir würden jetzt nicht sagen, ja, aber dann müssen die Taxis auch gratis sein oder so. Also deswegen ist das für mich nicht nachvollziehbar. Also ich finde, man kann nicht überall diese soziale Karte immer ziehen, denn damit will man eigentlich dann auch überhaupt nicht mehr in irgendeiner Richtung voran, beziehungsweise glaubt dann immer an so einem Einzelfenomen, die Ungleichheit aus der Welt schaffen zu können als ganzes. Und das ist einfach nicht möglich, sondern hier muss man erkennen, es ist sinnvoll, dass es so ist. Es war jetzt lange genug gratis, dass gratis Angebot Impfung besteht. Und jetzt können wir aber nicht noch dafür sorgen, dass das für alle, also dass das auch noch alle Verrücktheiten gratis weiterhin sein werden.
Ja, also Selektion über individuelle Kaufkraft ist primäres und normales maßgebendes Prinzip unserer Gesellschaft. Und wenn man das aufheben will, muss man es rechtfertigen. Dafür haben wir dann Politik. Da werden dann Malprogramme geschrieben und so weiter. Und die Rechtfertigungspflicht, warum das billig und kostenlos sein sollte, liegt bei denjenigen, die das kostenlos fordern und nicht bei denjenigen, die es kostenlos anbieten. In der Hinsicht haben wir hier ein Prinzip durchbrochen und gesagt, wir machen die Tests kostenlos. Warum? Na ja, weil es die beste Alternative ist zur Durchseuchung. Und jetzt haben wir aber eine bessere. Und dann ist es ganz normal, dass man halt sagt, ja, dann greifen jetzt wieder die alten Logiken. Man kann sich ja impfen lassen und die Impfung bleibt kostenlos. Selbst wenn man nicht krankenversichert ist, kriegt man die Impfung kostenlos. In der Hinsicht ist es, wie es ist. Und jetzt warten wir mal die Bundestagswahl ab.
Und solange können wir ja lesen und über gelesenes sprechen. Wir besprechen zusammen ja ein Buch, das wir gelesen haben, Inside Facebook, von zwei New York Times Journalistinnen. Und dieses Buch hat einen Untertitel, der sehr wertend ist, Die hässliche Wahrheit. Und wir werden ja dann feststellen, dass wir von der Wertung nicht viel finden.
Ein Buch völlig ohne Kommentar und Meinung.
Ganz, ganz eigenartig. Also ich fand manche Dinge dort noch mal sehr interessant zu lesen. So ist es nicht. Und da können wir auch über ein paar Dinge noch mal ganz klar reden. Was ist da mit Facebook jetzt eigentlich zu tun? Aber wir wollen ja auch dann darüber reden, was sind das eigentlich für Bücher, die hier so publiziert werden und dann auch gleichzeitig in allen Sprachen erscheinen? Also das ist ja gleichzeitig auf Deutsch und auf Französisch und so weiter, glaube ich, erschienen, dieses Buch.
Ja, genau, das machen wir den Rest nur kurz. Detlef Schäle interviewt sich einfach selbst in der Süddeutschen Zeitung, weil er ein Thema hat, das sich niemand interessiert. Detlef Schäle ist unser Arbeitsagenturchef. Und der kennt sich aus mit Rentenrepublik, der weiß Bescheid. Und ein Thema, das sich ja viele gewünscht haben, wir haben hier oder ich habe hier sehr wohlwollend über Blackrock gesprochen. Und die Greenwashing Vorwürfe wurden jetzt von dem ehemaligen Blackrock-ESG-Chef selbst nochmal aufgegriffen. Tariq Fancy, da wurde also auch in Deutschland nochmal interviewt von der Wirtschaftswoche. Ganz interessant gekoppelt daran, wir sind zementzüchtig und daran wird sich nichts ändern. Das heißt, ein Drittel unseres Klimabudgets ist schon mal weg für Zement. Da gibt es nämlich null Innovation. Und für alle, die ein ganz aufregendes Leben gerade haben, weil sie sich zähneknirschend fragen, wer wird denn jetzt Kanzler, habe ich ein Alternativprogramm. Einfach mal zu Hause aufräumen. Die Argumente sind schlagend.
Seid gespannt. Das ist aber nicht von Mary Condo, oder?
Nein, das ist von Kelsey Clark.
Und auch nicht von Jordan Peterson, der empfiehlt das ja auch. Warum eigentlich ein Zimmer aufräumen? Da kann ich auch noch etwas zu sagen, weil ich mit einem Psychiater darüber gesprochen habe, über Jordan Peterson, das Aufräumen vom Zimmer. Also das wird ganz gut. Den hatte ich auf einer Tagung ja in Bern getroffen. Ich habe das neue Buch von Werner Herzog gelesen und es hat jetzt Jahrzehnte gedauert, bis er mal wieder eins geschrieben hat. Das Dämmern der Welt. Es geht um einen einsamen Soldaten, einen Japaner, der im Zweiten Weltkrieg kämpft, auf einer Insel, die einen gewissen strategischen Nutzen haben soll, aber er bekommt das Ende des Krieges nicht mit. Und so kämpft er einsam 29 Jahre lang und wird dann irgendwann da dann rausgeholt. Man hat dann einen Weg und Werner Herzog hat natürlich diesen unglaublichen Mann auch getroffen und hat da einen ganz großartigen Text zugeschrieben. Dann, wie schon angekündigt, geht es um das Interview mit der Dorobär von Taiwan, Ort Ritang. Da wird man sehr erstaunt sein, was eigentlich so geht, wenn man so einen Posten hat bzw. wie gut man ihn besetzen könnte, wenn man dann will. Und dann werden wir ganz kurz auf das chinesische Fernsehen blicken. Da sollen Männer, die in Anführungszeichen weiblich auftreten, also stark geschminkt usw. die sollen da nicht mehr auftreten dürfen. Die sollen jetzt verbannt werden. Und das hat Gründe oder bzw. einen Grund vor allem. Dann überlegen wir mal mit dem IFO-Institut, wann eigentlich Steuern erhoben werden. Da hat das IFO-Institut eine Studie in zig Ländern, eine Studie gemacht, die zig Länder miteinander vergleicht. Und wir gucken noch nach El Salvador, denn dort wird Bitcoin als Währung jetzt eingeführt.
Lieblingsthema. Sehr gut. Sehr gut. Dann auf in den Salar. Bis gleich.
Bis gleich.